it was only
um like two weeks before i was
um introduced to heroin and crack
cocaine
i started using
recreationally and obviously like you
can't
do that with heroin before you become
addicted to it
demi lovato opens up about the first
time she ever used heroin
my cocktail before i got sober
was coke and xanax together it was
an upper and a downer and i loved the
combination
once i relapsed the floodgates were open
within a couple weeks
i called a drug dealer and i was like do
you have coke and xanax
and he said no but i have
crack and heroin and i was like
i've always wanted to try it episode 1
and 2 of the i love me singer's
four-part docu-series dancing with the
devil
dropped tuesday on youtube and the 28
year old's getting candid about her 2018
relapse and subsequent overdose demi
lovato is
no holds barred in this was there
anything
off limits for you guys she was even
surprised at just how much she ended up
wanting to share um which is all about
the safe space
and the ability you know to ultimately
get her story out there
cameras followed demi as she celebrated
six years of sobriety
this is a special day six years
sober
one month after that demi relapsed with
drugs and alcohol
and within three months she was fighting
for her life
i picked up a bottle of red wine that
night and it wasn't even
30 minutes before i called someone that
i knew had drugs on them
i ended up at a party i just so happened
to run into my old drug dealer
from six years before and
i just went to town that night i did
drugs that i'd never done before
i'd never done meth before i tried meth
i mixed it with molly with coke
weed alcohol oxycontin and like that
alone should have killed me
demi says two weeks after that she tried
heroin and crack cocaine for the first
time
and during a trip to bali a few weeks
later the former disney star said she
realized she had become physically
dependent on it
it was on that trip that she wrote her
emotional track
sober
[Music]
i went away i went on tour to europe
um i stayed clean kind of
like wasn't doing drugs but was drinking
a lot
etie spoke to the documentary's director
michael d
ratner and he opened up about why it was
so important to demi to lay it all out
on the table
i think she feels liberated i think she
feels like she doesn't have to walk
around
with a facade or wondering are people
going to pick up on this or
you know i've said i'm the poster child
for that but people evolve people grow
and you know there's no there's going to
be no aha gotcha moment after this she
says
i am a work in progress i've put systems
in place because i am a flawed person
here's where i am today and i'm i'm here
to tell you my journey when i came back
to la
after tour i picked up where
i had left off and i was
very heavily using demi overdosed and
was rushed to the hospital on july
24 2018. metro rescue 827
persons leaving does not want lasd
assistance and or help
i am not saying that i have not used
needles but that night i wasn't
injecting it i was smoking it
which is another reason why i was so
shocked when i woke up in the hospital
because i was like
no i'm not injecting it i can't overdose
on it
at the end of the day if you do too much
of anything it's gonna kill you her
objective was to
clear the air to tell her story to speak
her truth you could jump on live and
say whatever you're feeling that day but
that's impulsive and in the moment
whereas this
is you know you're gonna get to know
demi lovato through and through
in this piece